dafür dass ich noch anschauen ob wie
viel jahren ist auf krank mama ab wie
viel jahren ist auf krankenschein ok
schon okay ich schau nur gerade ein
upgrade video services und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ich saß
heute am kaffeetisch mit meiner oma und
dachte mir weißt du was ein gewürz zeit
für neuen großen wie auch die letzten
tage habe ich mir davon euch auf twitter
vorschläge machen lassen und es kamen
leute
es kam ein video vor wo von wem
überlegt mal um welchen youtuber können
sich heute handeln wieder sitzt bisschen
dumm weiß wahrscheinlich im zusammenhang
steht selbstverständlich ist wie beim
durch genaue antworten ein video
besonders aufgefallen und zwar von
niemand geringerem als apo med eine
sache noch bevor wir den braten in den
ofen schieben ich hab mir heute wie
angeschaut von der heyden was ich
ziemlich gut fand in dem er auch noch
mal betont hat dass diese ganzen
kommentares oder reaction videos auf
videos die einem selbst persönlich nicht
so gefallen über die man sich lustig
macht halt selbst auch nur spaß sind
leute
man kann ja nicht sagen okay das gefällt
mir jetzt nicht so gut auf youtube ich
mache jetzt ein video drüber und
verursacht damit dann die übelste hate
und hass welle macht youtube noch
schlechter das kann nicht das ziel der
sache seien deswegen wünsche mir von
euch dass wir uns zusammen gehört dass
amüsieren was andere so auf youtube
verzapfen
aber das nicht gerettet wird und niemand
beleidigt wird und niemand der tod
gewünscht wird lange super nachdem wir
das geklärt haben gehen wir doch einfach
mal auf diese perle deutscher
zeitgeschichte auf dieses meisterwerk
der videokunst 4000 euro für viele
sachen xxl fashion park opening und
gucken einfach mal was uns da erwartet
ich bin übrigens gerade an maxis pc wie
ihr vielleicht im hintergrund erkennt
das heißt ich bin auch an seinem account
eine logo und unser werter kollege ist
vor zwei millionen abos da müssen doch
direkt mit maxis discounter weiter wobei
nämlich und und dann würde ich sagen wir
mal ab was oft trocken und weiteren
video und bevor das wieder anfangen
großen aufruf starten und zwar bleibt
mein neues bilder fenster ist euch
aufgefallen diese das untere ende seines
pullis so richtig leuchtet alter das
untere ende leuchtete richtig krass das
kann nur ein zeichen dafür sein dass
upgrade auf dem weg ist sich vom
youtuber dasein ins heiligen dasein zu
begeben er ist im prozess der
transzendenz er ist gerade auf dem weg
in den himmel unter anderem mit 10.000
des lecks zu 40.000 like bisschen was
wir gehen hier mal ein like ganz ehrlich
was ist das denn aussieht aus wenig
platz
dass die glatze nicht von hier in nach
außen geht sondern von hier unten nach
oben das ist die berühmte
zentraleuropäische wander glatze hier
ein sehr bemitleidenswerte mensch der
von dieser wirklich schrecklichen
krankheit betroffen ist wer kennt es
daran dass seine haare von unten nach
oben ausfallen
ein paar sachen die ich mir gegönnt habe
heute im heimischen bereich hat etwas
extravaganter exklusiver und etwas
teurer so weit bei einigen sogar ein
schnäppchen gemacht habe schnäppchen
schnäppchen was unter 800 euro
ein t shirt für 1000 euro als 1050 davor
gekostet die egal was für ein schnell
das erste paket da will man hier und wir
checken mal ab was ist vom leser die
aroma ist es keine marke sondern einfach
nur das erzählte man sich aus wie das
liga verpackungen über das dazu an sich
beobachtet da schon mal ganz süß machst
du einfach auf 18 euro
wir haben einmal kann es kosten soll
was kosten seien korrekt com was hat sie
gekostet jetzt aber noch nicht um den
heißen brei herum gehört man so zwischen
308 immer so ist schon eine relativ
normale des teams
das ist hier wichtiger also dürfen
hausen und es ist ja jedem selbst
überlassen nicht viel geld er für mode
ausgibt kann jeder machen wie er möchte
und ich kann auch verstehen wenn man als
youtuber auf der suche nach einem video
idee ist und man einfach bereit ist
alles zu nehmen und bereit sich selbst
auszuziehen und ich laufe nackt auf die
straße bringt zu machen hauptsache man
kann ein video machen aber so dieses
krasse zurschaustellen von wegen
ich habe soviel an schwierigkeit 4004
sachen ausgeben menschen nicht gesehen
ziemlich abstoßend ist ein t-shirt mit
dem aufdruck vorn drauf was ist dass
irgendein gemälde und auf den ärmeln auf
dem rücken sind landung streifen bzw auf
dem rücken sohn fadenkreuz da kommen auf
jeden fall schon mal einen raushauen
leute ich bin gespannt auf die reaktion
von justin also erkennt justin ja
bestimmt es jetzt so ein bisschen in die
fashion szene abgewandert macht er sein
ding ganz gut finde ich richtig cool was
er macht freund justin rastet er immer
so richtig aus wenn youtuber die er
nicht so feiert of wight sachen kaufen
beim igel pablo scheint ja auch schon so
kurz vor sein leben zu beenden und aus
dem fenster zu springen
wien apa red ich weiß gar nicht warum
sie günstige einfach eine homo alter das
ist keine erbsenzählerei leute aber sind
wir in der fucking steinzeit muss ich
jetzt jedes mal wenn ich jetzt diesen
baby blue kollege trage jedes video mit
einer homo beginnen weil leute sonst
denken dass ich schwul bin weil ich
einen blauen pullover tragen oder wenn
ich einen pinken rudi trage den maut für
die alle leute die haben alle jungs habt
ihr nur gesagt bevor dann gezogen habt
ehrlich seid ehrlich als kombi eines
gemäldes
ok es muss aber raushole also wenn es
800 euro mit den ersten zwei sachen das
heißt wir müssen die anderen beiden
sachen ja 3200 kosten
ob er das hinbekommt oder ob der titel
vielleicht nicht zu 100 prozent geklärt
ist wir haben jetzt stets wir haben die
sweat shirt of nice nice leute wisst ihr
was mittlerweile wird youtube hat echt
wirklich lustig so ich habe mittlerweile
aufgeholt einfach leute die so ein
bisschen nichts in mein weltbild passen
einfach zu retten sondern ich amüsiere
mich einfach drüber ich finde es
wirklich einfach nur noch lustig ist
trainer hat mich nicht zum beispiel
jetzt ihr er muss einfach egal was er
macht fohlen definieren auf was macht
das heißt wer zwischen morgens aufsteht
sagt immer mal wieder zum bäcker müsst
ihr natürlich auch mutter vorhersagen
auf was ihr zum bäcker geht die tür auf
nice austrocknen auf fresh oder auf
normal zum bäcker das nicht definiert
müsst ihr euch darauf einstellen dass
eure mutter danach fragt liga ein bein
ganz deutschland aber so drauf hat ist
er so witzig wir haben richtig ich sage
mir das gleiche erwarte einige der mich
hoch genommen
leute die haben mich hoch also wirklich
hoch genau mich umgebracht er hat mich
geküsst wird diejenige was ist das mein
dicker ich habe eine heftige allerdings
gleichen voll auf und korrekt von denen
alter merkel 42 700 euro dritter artikel
sind wir bei 15 das heißt der dritte
artikel müsste 2500 kosten
eine jobgarantie alte schwede auf krank
dafür dass ich noch anschauen
aber wie viel jahren ist auf krank mama
ab wie viel jahren ist auch krank in es
ist ja ok schon okay ich schaue gerade
apa/red video billiger 2 1 sein das
heißt revision macht ihr noch mal ein
dreckiger auf vernichtung das kranke ins
gewicht von 2 cache notiert 1 400 hose
400 policen 800 hatte sich noch
rausgeholt in polierter zweimal als
schick einen zurück und dann die
bomberjacke für 18 sind drei kleine
rechenfehler ist in dem fall vor dem
titel geschuldet aber alles in allem
muss man sagen es ist noch ein relativ
harmloses video von reiter seit dem
bombenkrieg aller sich verbessert hat
schon so leichte gehirn ausfälle auch in
diesem video gehabt sagt es ist die
einzige jack in europa schmeißt sie erst
mal auf dem boden um das zu zelebrieren
aber das kann ja noch verzeihen das was
im heutigen video leute wenn ihr neues
video haben wollt dann springt man den
like button bei 4 likes mache ich ein
neues video in diesem sinne
haut rein macht's gut